what's going on I'm Chris Bosh and this
is that's my guy did dad work as a
corrections officer his mom paid for his
first tattoo and he was the first player
ever to get called up from the D League
today that was a teammate of mine you
know we always don't share life stories
first guy get called up from the D
League man oh yeah my guy bird man I had
to remember that didn't I know is that
the corrections officer he's played war
in Ukraine Israel and the TV and he has
a massive sneak attack
PJ Tucker easy I just saw him in Japan
with some he wore swimming trunks to a
function true story
you know I don't know where he's doing
but he's doing it you know what I mean
tie-dye he's super 70s with 90s in there
and I guess the choker changed with the
mm I'm REO Chalmers and you know why I
know it's real because he's told me the
same exact accolades that you just told
me real will let you know as my godoh
was a real he was in though this is my
party music video and him and his cousin
were in Leeds
ah you see you sneaking stuff in with
the drives by the go to state that's
Vince because he got drafted by Golden
State and they traded that's a good one
you almost almost got me with out almost
fell for that one and the fact that he
can still dunk at 43 is crazy
he was the Wayne Wade you know being one
of the most beautiful people in the
world is very important everything he's
doing and you know People magazine
best-selling author you know the whole
lifestyle thing he's like the black male
Martha Stewart or so he's got everything
really the first one take my picture
yeah I'm Chris Bosh and you just watched
that's my guy